哈喽大家好
欢迎回到Lindsay的频道
你知道吗
全球每天平均要喝掉
22.5亿杯咖啡
这是什么概念
你看全球一共才81个人
也就是说平均4个人里边
就有一个人每天要喝掉一杯咖啡
像我们平时喝的
比如说素容咖啡
瓦尔庄咖啡
胶囊咖啡
去咖啡厅喝的咖啡
咖啡粉 咖啡豆
还有那种听着很厉害的什么
来山咖啡 猫屎咖啡等等等等
你就发现这里头
竟然也有这么一条鄙视链了
所以今天咱们就来聊一聊
到底什么样的咖啡才是好咖啡
怎么样喝咖啡就能喝出B格
什么
哈哈哈哈
说到这咖啡
其实它做出来主要分三个步骤
首先先种豆
第二步就把它烘焙成
这个咖啡豆
就咱平时那种看着黑乎乎的
第三步是把它给研磨好了之后
做成咖啡
但是其实每一步
都彰显着这个咖啡的B格
我们先来说说这个原材料
因为我平时看到的那些咖啡豆
就黑不溜秋都已经烤好了的那种
我开始以为这个咖啡豆
它是长在地里头的
就跟一个种子一样
飞
这咖啡呢
是长在树上的
然后它从一棵树
咖啡树上
结出来了那种小果子
特别漂亮
红红的
跟个小樱桃似的
你如果把那个瓶给扒开
里边这两瓣
这就是我们平时看到的
那个咖啡的
就相当于生的状态
有的时候我们把它叫做绿咖啡
就是green coffee
我们平时喝的咖啡
其实最常见的分两大类
一类叫做Arabica
一类叫做Robusta
就是阿拉比卡和罗布斯塔
这两种豆呢
我先说结论
简而言之就是阿拉比卡
不是这个
这样我们把它简称叫阿豆和螺豆好了
这个阿豆呢
一般来讲是比这个螺豆更优质的
这是结论大家记住了
所以如果你挑想要地格高一点的豆
我们就找这种阿拉比卡
百分之百的阿拉比卡
比如说你看像这种
这不是恰饭
就你可以看得很清楚
它这会写是百分之百的阿拉比卡
就说明它这里边不参查罗布斯塔
就有一些它上面会写
with a touch of 罗布斯塔
这种你不知道它那个 touch
踏实的多踏实
所以就尽量还是选100%的
比如说下次你去男朋友家
你看他买的咖啡豆
你看 哎 罗巴斯塔
那你这时候就得跟他们说
哦 亲爱的
这个罗巴斯塔的咖啡因含量太高了
会让你心慌
对你身体不好
所以之后我们一定要买
阿拉比卡豆
这样就可以一扫你女汉子的形象
立马就变成一个特别清诚可爱
迷人的小女生
这两种豆最主要的区别
一个是咖啡因的含量
一个是它的一些咖啡的风味的元素
咖啡因就是罗布斯塔豆要更高一些
因为罗布斯塔它叫robusta
英文就是robust 对吧
就是感觉特别强壮
咖啡因含量高也能让它更好的去强壮
就抵抗外界的这些环境
就是更磁石 不怎么挑环境
像罗豆就一般是东半球
比如说像越南 印尼还有非洲的一些地方产的会比较多所以我不知道大家有没有喝过那种越南咖啡叫Vietnamese咖啡就感觉它那里边厚田厚田给你加好多又是糖精又是糖浆这些东西就是因为它那产的那种豆都是螺豆
就刺激性很强
所以它得要特别甜的东西
然后就冲掉那些苦涩
阿豆呢
on the other side
就比较娇嫩
没那么好养活
它没有那么高的咖啡因含量
所以它抵抗外界环境的能力就差一些
所以你得给它更多的呵护
就感觉像个千金大小姐一样
但是大小姐有大小姐的美
对吧
它就更多的糖
更多的脂
所以还有其他的一些风味元素
所以整个喝起来
咖啡的那个感觉
口感啊味道啊
就感觉更高级一些
所以它也是在比试链的上段
像我们平时有的时候
你听说那些产地
感觉很厉害的地方
什么亚迈加的蓝山咖啡
还有什么曼特宁咖啡
特纳咖啡
像这些地方呢
主要都是产阿拉比卡
第二个步骤
就是这个烘焙
读烘焙
千万不要读烘焙
你都烘焙就太掉价了
就比如说你有的时候去星巴克
你要买那个主的就是Brewed Coffee
你就看那是三个大桶
对吧
一个写的Blond
就是感觉轻度烘焙的
烘焙的
然后第二个是那个Medium
Medium Roast就是中度
然后第三个呢
是Dark Roast就是重度
比如说你去买咖啡的时候也是
你看像这个
这个这种呢
就是它是一个Light Roast
就是轻度的烘焙
然后呢
比如说你看像这个
我还今天特意把我们家里
所有的咖啡都搬出来了
你看这个呢
就写的是Medium Roast
就是中度的
这个豆看这儿
就是属于dark roast
就是中度的
这是什么意思呢
其实就有点相当于
比如你要去点个牛排
或者你要煎鸡蛋
你要几分熟
对吧
你要三分熟
五分熟还是七分熟
那就是轻度中度和重度
如果说是轻度
它就会感觉可能更生一点
然后你会感觉到那种草本的酸涩
比如说下一次
你再跟朋友出去喝咖啡
朋友喝了一口说
这咖啡怎么感觉酸酸的呢
这时候支持点就可以上来了
你说它酸可能
因为它是轻度烘焙的
不如我们来一杯这么多烘焙的怎么样
然后再往后它越来温度越高
温度越高之后
咖啡里头水分蒸发了
然后糖就慢慢的焦糖化了
然后油也一点一点就被烘出来了
所以你越往后
它豆本身颜色越深
然后再开始有点发光发亮
你喝的时候也会感觉像碳烤的那种
感觉更纯一点更甜一点
更感觉roasted
这种一般来讲就是重度的
一般来讲就是那种特别好的咖啡豆
或者说有点咖啡那种发烧油
他们要品咖啡
就是评价那个咖啡的时候
这种情况下他们一般是会选
更轻度的就是light roasted这种的咖啡
因为这种可能它没有那么重的碳化
那么重后面的整个化学反应
它保持的这个咖啡本身
原有的那个风味就更足一点其实一般抹好的咖啡豆它是可以保存很长时间的但是一定要注意的就是要避光避热避潮下次如果你看有朋友把咖啡豆放在冰箱里充满知识点的小可爱就又要上线了
就说这咖啡豆
千万不能放在冰箱里
冰箱太潮了
还有一个
我之前去买咖啡
你去超市
你经常看这咖啡上
就有这么一个小孔
你看就像这个
能看到这儿有一个气孔
对吧
我最开始看到这个气孔的时候
我就拿着咖啡这么一挤
哇好香啊
哇 好香啊
我又觉得这个设计简直太人性化了
我可以想看这咖啡豆闻一遍
然后感觉哪个气味我最喜欢
我就买哪一个
这根本就不是给你闻的
这口呢
它其实是一个单向的气阀
因为咖啡豆在烘好之后呢
它是会排出来一些二氧化碳的气体
其实是给这咖啡豆
起到一个保护的作用
所以它防止这个大尔特贵账
它就得有一个单向的气阀
它是单向的吧
就不让氧气啊
其他东西进去腐蚀这个咖啡豆
人家是咖啡的保护气体
你给人都挤出来了
你还想不想让人家咖啡
都好好活着
所以以后这个千万不能挤
这个太low了
好 我们来说这个最后一步
不管你是叫做咖啡
泡咖啡
冲咖啡
煮咖啡
专业的名词就叫萃取
比如说咱学会这个词
下次你跟你男朋友
出去喝咖啡的时候
你就说
我们现在到了最后一个萃取的步骤
就会感觉特别文艺
我为什么不用带小姑娘出去的
可能因为我上次被人骂了
你这样有点太固化女性的形象了
不太好
所以咱们下次
小瓜跟男朋友也可以
萃取听着很专业
其实说白了
它就是把咖啡里面那些味儿
融到水里头
其实一般你会听到很多各种各样
感觉很厉害的做法
就是什么手冲咖啡
挂尔咖啡
什么法式French Press
但是我觉得对咱们普通人来讲
可能主要可以分成两大类
一类是浸泡式
一类是意识浓缩
我们先说这个浸泡式
浸泡式就是我们平时在家里
建的比较多的
就是让咖啡粉
咖啡抹好了之后
粉跟水充分的接触
要么你是弄个咖啡机对吧
水加热完之后
从咖啡粉里头过出去
滤出来一杯咖啡
或者是有那种
感觉很厉害的手冲咖啡
然后那个小漏斗
这溜下来
手冲咖啡挺漂亮的
再有就是像那种
我要吐个槽
有一个发明叫挂耳式咖啡
就是一个密封的咖啡袋
然后打开之后
夹在杯子上
就像两个耳朵一样挂在杯子上
这个它竟然是日本的一个发明
它就从此之变成个专利了
这这个
然后手冲的这种
一般最好你得现磨
让咖啡的风味最饱满的时候
然后你再一冲泡
这样你才能得到一杯最香浓
最醇厚的咖啡
比较优雅
在那很安静的一个下午
拿着一尾书
手冲一杯咖啡
享受一个惬意的午后
就会给人一种很安静
我觉得还挺就是relaxing的那种感觉
另一种挺常见的
就是那种意识浓缩的咖啡机这个就是你去像什么星巴克或者其他基本所有的咖啡厅都用的那种很大的意识咖啡机就是机器很大然后每次弄个咖啡粉然后再弄个小东西给你弄弄压压压
然后放进去
然后就开始那个水弄下来
那种它是在9个大气压的情况下
在92度的水温
用25毫升的水萃取30毫升的咖啡液
要的就是这个精准
所以它最主要的
跟刚才浸泡式的区别
就是它是通过高压
它是9个大气压
要不然你想那个水肯定过不去
那么细的浓缩咖啡粉
加压之后呢
就让这个水尽量的少
所以最后得到的就是浓缩的咖啡液
所以它喝起来就不会像刚才那个那么水
这种呢一般你可以单喝
就叫espresso
然后呢你也可以跟各种其他的奶啊
奶沫啊巧克力酱啊搭配
就是我们平时经常
你要喝拿铁 摩卡 卡普奇诺
这些各种各样不同的搭配
都是易式浓缩来的
这种一般机器还挺贵的
所以自己在家
可能你很少看买那种一个大机器
但它确实萃取很多香气
包括带那种沫
然后味道也比较好
所以很多人也是很想
在家里自己做这个
所以当时雀巢就出来了
Nespresso
就是可以自己在家做
Espresso
当然只有这种浓缩的咖啡
它打出来
才会有那种上面一层咖啡沫
就是喝着感觉
那个泡沫也很香的感觉
因为那个
我们之前小林老师给大家讲过
这是因为那个咖啡里头
有那种表面活性剂的成分
然后它里面又没有那么多水
因为是浓缩的嘛
所以才能打出来那层沫
但像刚才我们说的那种
浸泡式的咖啡
因为水的浓度太大了
所以就不太会形成那种泡沫
这个呢
喝着就还是感觉挺醇厚
挺香甜的
而且我自己是特别喜欢
去咖啡厅里
闻那个咖啡机的
打出来那个粉末的那个香气
心旷神怡
好 下次我们可就知道怎么点了
比如说下次你跟男朋友
去我们久违的小林奶茶店
然后咱们也得喝杯咖啡对吧
这时候你就可以说
我可以想要一杯
蓝山的阿拉比卡豆
我要中度烘焙
然后最后可以给我来一个
Espresso Double Shot
无糖无奶
谢谢
这时候你男朋友在边上就会说
给我来一杯一样的
其实说白了
刚才彼时链也是开玩笑的
我觉得只要你喝得高兴
喝得开心
然后你能享受到咖啡
给你带来的那个比较舒适的感觉
那喝什么都是随你
但那是咖啡里面
其实是有咖啡印的
所以你不要一天喝太多
要不然有的时候
你就晚上睡不着觉啊
什么就不太好
当然喝咖啡也有好处
据我和我身边的朋友报告显示
咖啡具有通常排练的作用
所以有些人早上喝一杯催死咖啡
也是有利于调整你的生活作息
行 今天就分享到这儿
拜拜
开始是吗
直接开始
嗯 好
你笑什么
哈喽大家好
欢迎回到另一段频道
我们今天
哪个女生拿这么大瓶子喝水